ah the slim-jim
four inches of spicy salty processed
meat like goodness so what goes into
this stuff the packaging calls it a meat
stick and meat there is depending on
your definition the most processed meats
use the bottom three categories of beef
utility cutter and canner
they come from older cows with less
marbling ConAgra wouldn't tell us which
type they use but go ahead and use your
imagination the beef base is filled up
with mechanically separated chicken the
pink extruded paste used in some chicken
nuggets but it's not just animal in
there there's a dose of corn and wheat
proteins to along with hydrolyzed soy
the soy proteins get broken down into
amino acids including glutamic acid
that's the one behind savory you mammy
tastes everything else helps the stick
stay preserved inside its plastic just
like a real sausage lacto bacteria feed
on the sugar dextrose to reduce lactic
acid which keeps the pH low and the
bacteria out there's also salt lots of
salt one sixth of your daily dose in
fact it also suppresses microbes finally
there's sodium nitrate it helps prevent
botulism and also combines with the
myoglobin in animal muscle to keep your
snack reddish instead of an unappetizing
gray Bon Appetit feeling wired yet
subscribe